I just turned eighteen,...
...and there are still so many things that I don't know about the world.
But what I do know is that it's hard to admit that you might be part of the problem,...
...that all of us might be part of the problem.
So instead of giving you a step-by-step guide on how to not be racist towards Asians,...
...I will let you decide what to take from this talk.
All I can do is share my story.
My name is Canwen, my favorite color is purple...
...and I play the piano, but not so much the violin.
I have two incredibly supportive, hardworking parents...
...and one very awesome ten-year-old brother.
I love calculus more than anything, despise eating rice...
...and I'm a horrendous driver.
But most of all, I am proud of who I am:...
...a little bit American, a little bit Chinese and a whole lot of both.
Thank you.